can you tears [ __ ] Cheers
[Music]
hi mom hi you look beautiful thank you
for saying that we're gearing up for a
very exciting day are you excited I'm
getting there I don't want to give them
any major spoilers until we get there
but you look absolutely stunning oh
thank you a daughter was here forever
we're going on an excursion today in
honor of my mom's birthday and if you
follow me on social media you probably
are you know exactly where we've got
remember me as I am right now because
things are going to get gifts
oh and I see
Hightower you're moving in the distance
guys the towers right there this is
beautiful medieval times right next to
Arthur's pub and quality in
[Music]
this is my castle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have overstimulated really really
quickly
[Applause]
[Music]
finally substances if the Blue Knight
loses I'll just die oh my god if from
your white horse that comes out and runs
by itself
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
Oh God show me the way because the devil
shot I'm going on the Frog life right
now
oh I don't care your father's very proud
of you
[Music]
[Music]
the morning after medieval times my mom
is Anna beautiful I'll pink jogging suit
and what do we go what I going to go to
right now we're hoping to earth for us
ever water Google glass taking a water
Zumba class this morning yeah perfect
after medieval times activity absolutely
let's go do it because they after that
was a journey that was them does fun
time it's early love we got a lot of
cultural experiences in one 45-minute
class we got some hip hop we got some
oldies we did Riverdance all together at
one point that was probably all held
hands and did River death in the water
and then we ended with proud to be an
American right since it's Memorial Day
so it was a it was a lot it's a good
lesson in like you just never know what
you're going to be doing yes it says
jump in the pool and hold a woman's hand
and Riverdance and see where it takes
you don't know I'm just other statute
solo it's all good happy Memorial Day
everyone from law real bad
I live in the moment break